[موسيقى]
يعطيكم العافيه اليوم حابه احكي لكم قصه
صغيره قصه عن عيله صغيره هاي العيله مكونه
من بنت اسمها بطله بطله عايشه مع امها
وجدتها الام اسمها نديمه والجده اسمها
عتيقه هلا بطله من اول ما وعيت على
هالدنيا وكانت جدي عتيقه الكل في الكل في
البيت يعني ما في اشي بيمشي بالبيت بشورها
المهم
عتيقه كانت اخ الاربعينات بس هي ترملت
باول العشرين جدي عتيقه تؤمن ان البنت
احسن من الولد وعلى اساسه ربت بنتها نديمه
اللي هي ام بطله واخوها الجدي عتيقه دقه
قديمه قديمه كتير واسيا اسيا كتير جدي
عتيقه كانت كل همها تكبر بنتها وانها تصير
بالجامعه وبالمدرسه بس هذا الحكي مش مضبوط
كانت دائما مين تحلم فيه بطله فبطله ما
كانت تستوعب ليش الجده عتيقه كتير كتير
قاسيه ودقه قديمه وكمان عندها هذا التمييز
فكانت تسالها
ليه هيك عم بصير في البيت فكانت ترد عليها
جداتي اتسكتها وتقول لها
البنات مش لازم يسالوا كتير لانه بكره
بحكوا عنك قويه وكاستره وبتضلي عندي ما
بتتجوزي وبتعنسي الام نديمه كانت باغلب
الاحيان ما تحب حكي جدي عتيقه بس ما كانت
تحكي ولا اشي الام نديمه ما كملت تعليمها
لان الجدي عتيقه لما ترملت كان همها انها
تكبر هالبنت وتجوزها وتستر عليها وفعلا
اول حدا دق الباب
زوجته اياها جدي عتيقه لانه بنظرها كان
منيح الام نديمه ما كانت حتى مطبقه 18 مع
هيك زوجتها وحكتلها بيت زوجك هو بيتك من
يوم وطالع وسترته من سترتك فعلا الامنا دي
متزوجه وراحت عبيت زوجها ما مرق اكم من
شهر الا وهي راجعه عند جدي عتيقه عينها
نافخ عاتبتها جدي عتيقه وقالت لها شو ما
لحقنا نجوزك ترجعي لنا حردانه الله اعلم
انت شو عامله لا هو يضربك وبهيك جبرتها
جدي عتيقه
طب اغراضها وتمسح دمعتها وترجع عند زوجها
وقالت لها كوني الطف معه واصلا ضرب الحبيب
تزبيب سحبت حالها ورجعت الام نديمه وعاشت
عند زوجها بس الوضع ما انعدل ابدا اليوم
ما اكتشفت انها حامل ببطله
هلا برات الايام وانولدت بطله
وكانت سعادتها كتير كتير كتير الام نديم
بنتها لدرج سمتها بطله ام نديمه وعدت
بنتها انها ما تخليها تحس بالاشياء اللي
هي حست فيها بس الجدي عتيقه ما كانت كتير
مبسوطه ببطله ليه مش لانها ما بتحبها هلا
انولدت بطله بس لانه بطله بنت وعندي جدي
عتيقه هم البنات
للممات والاولاد ما بعيبهم ولا اشي
كالعاده الام نديمه عم تسمع ومش عاجبها بس
هي ملتهيه انولدت بطله هلا
ونسيت كل كلام الجده عتيقه ونسيت انها
حترجع على هم العنف المنزلي بستناها
بالبيت وفعلا سحبت حالها ورجعت عبيت زوجها
ومعها بنتها الصغيره بطله بس العون ما وقف
بالعكس زاد مع وجود بطله يا مره سكتي
هالبنت يا مره ليش البيت وسخ يا مره قومي
اعملي الاكل ليش لهلا مش عامله اكل
وينها الام نديمه بنتها الرضيعه الجديده
وينها كل شغل البيت اللي فوق راسها وين
هالعنف والاهانات والصراخ المستمره لايجي
يوم مكسر الدنيا على راسها هون الام نديمه
قررت ما تسكت وتسحب حالها وترجع عند جده
عتيقه وحكتلها على الجده انا رجعه مش
راجعه وبدي اطلع وتسمح لكم جدي عتيقه كلمه
طلاق من هون وتقول لها شو انا يكون عندي
بنات مطلقات انا يحكوا عني ما عرفت اربي
وترجعي لي عندي على البيت ستره البنت
زاجتها ترد عليها الام نديمه لاول مره
بتتجرا وبتقول لها سترتها حتى لو بده
يقتلها باي شارع هاد طبعا انصدمت جدي
عتيقه ما ردت عليها وبعد سكوت حكتلها
طب وبنتك بطله مين بده يربيها بديك تربيها
بلا اب ولا بدك بكره يحكوا عنك انها بنت
المطلقه
فعلا
الامه ديمه سحبت حالها ورجعت عنده وهو
طبعا شو استقوى وضله يقول لي على انه انت
ما عندك لا سند ولا ضهر ومن مبسوط كتير
بتعتيبها المهم
قررت تضلها صابره ومتحمله في يوم من
الايام وبطله بعدها بتحدي اجا كالعاده
ضربها بس هالمره ماذا
صحيت الام دينا في المستشفى
حواليها الجيران وحواليها الشرطه حتى الام
جدتها العتيقه وكمان اخوها
وهون الشرطي قالها بطله ابوها لانه الاب
هو ولي الامر
فحكت للشرطي انا ما بدي اشي بس بدي اتطلق
وتكون البنت معي
فعليا اخوها امشي بالاجراءات بس هون الام
نديمه بلشت في معاناه جديده معاناه
الولايه والحضانه طبعا الام نديمه تنازلت
عن كل اشي عشان تتطلق منه ومع انه الحضانه
بايدها
بس الولايه بايده يعني بكره اذا بدك
تسجلها في المدرسه او بدها توديها على
المستشفى فللاب السلطه المطلقه هو كان
فاهم هذا الاشي وحاب يضلوا يبتزدها بهذا
الموضوع ويحكي لها بيقدر يسحب منها بطل
باي وقت بحجه انه يحكي عنها مش مناسبه
باسم القانون يسحب منها بطله
صارت الام نديمه تعيش بين نارين
نار الطليق المهتز اللي بس بده يذلها باسم
القانون
وناري جده عتيقه اللي شايفيتها عاليه
عليها خاصه انا رجعت لها مطلع بعمره
عشرينات مع طفل صغيره بس الام نديمه رجعت
وعدت بطله وعد انه تخليها تكبر وتدرس
وتشتغل عشان ما يصير فيها اللي صار فعلا
مرقه الايام هي مراه السنين وبطله كبرت
صارت بعمر الجامعه والام نديمه وراها خطب
خطوه حتى صارت تقررلها احسن تخصص حبس بطله
تعرف بالضبط شو بدها وما قبلت اي حدا
ينقينا التخصص لا الام نديمه ولا الجده
عتيقه وفعلا مشت اللي براسها ودرست التخصص
اللي بدها اياه
وبيوم من الايام وهي راجعه من الجامعه صار
الحوار الاتي ما بينهم بطله كتير معصبه
ومتضايقه
اليوم
اجا شاب وقتل بنت جوا الجامعه
فبترد عليها على السريع الام نديمه وبتقول
لها اللي هي شو عملت ترجع بترد عليها جد
عتيقه وبتقول لها ما هو يا مش لابسه مضبوط
شو اسمه بحبه هذا الجيل
فبترد عليهم بطله لا هيك ولا هيك ولا هيك
اصلا هي ما بتعرفه ومش بس هيك حتى لو يعني
عادي يقتلها
بحكوا انه هو كتير كاين يتحرش فيها ولحقها
على كل مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
بترد عليها الجده عتيقه مواقع شو هذا
الجيل الله يرحم ايامنا ما حدا فاهم منكم
كل شي صار عندكم تحرش فبترد عليها بطله
وبتقول لها
ايامكم ايام شو ايام الافلام اللي فيها شو
اسمه اصلا ما ضيعنا غير هاي الافلام اللي
صرت تفكروا فيها تحرش اشي حلو فبتايد على
الام نديم بتقولها اه والله خلينا على
هدول المسلسلات اللي فيها حاره فبتحكي لهم
بطله يا هيك يا هيك ما في حل وسط يعني
فبتضحك معها وبتمزح الشده عتيقه وبتقول
لها
تخيلي هلا بعد هالعمر يجي واحد يحكي كم
كلمه صار تحرش فبتايدها الام نديمه وبتقول
لها اه والله ميتو
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
يمه وحل شعرهم
والله وهي قمر
[موسيقى]
خلوني اخليكم خليني اخلط لكم
المهم مراه الايام ومرات السنين وبطله مش
بتخلص بكالوريوس
ماجستير كمان
وراها كالعاده لام نديمه ماشيه خطوه بخطوه
ولاقت شغل احلامها بطله بس ما لقت بسهوله
كان مشوارها صعب اشي يقولها بدك تتزوجي
ليش نستثمر فيك طيب ما انت حتطلعي وشيء
يقول لها
يعني بكره بس تتزوجي بدك تجيبي اولاد يعني
عمومي وحضانه وفتره يعني همومه ومصاري
وهيك
واشيلها احنا بس بدنا نتفاعلك اقل من
زميلك اللي بنفس المرتبه مش لاشي هو عنده
مسؤوليات ترد عليهم بطني طب وانا هيني
فاتحه البيت كامل بالجدية أبو الام نديمه
ما كان سهل مشوارها ابدا وكانت تتمنى لو
البيئه كانت شوي مساعده اكتر لتفوت سوق
العمل وتستمر فيها المهم
كان قرب عيد ميلادها الثلاثين لبطله
ومين كان قاعد حوالينا يا عيله بيحتفلوا
ودار الحوار الاتي الام نديمه انا كتير
مبسوطه انك ترقيتي في شغلك اليوم بس ما
بدك تتزوجي وتفتحي بيت وتستقر ليه
فبتنط على السريع جدي عتيقه وبتقول لها
ليش انت يعني ما تضيع مثال تتزوج وصل حتى
لو بدها تتزوج مين بده يتزوج بنت اللي
مطلقه
فبتمتم كالعاده الام نديمه مش عاجبها بس
ما حكت غير هالكم كلمه ما هي ام صبحي
اليوم مرقت طلبتها
بتنط بطل استنى استنى شوي
بكالوريوس خلصنا وماجستير وخلصنا واحلى
شغل وعندنا فاتحه بيت فيكم يا احلى قمرات
استقروا كامل مكمله مش ناقصني شيء عتيقه
زمن الاول حول شو يعني طلاق ما طلع اثنين
كانوا مع بعض
زبطت امورهم عادي
بعدين هي نهايه خضره اول حدا بدق الباب
يلا اي اذا انا بدي انقي فستان بكون مش
مخليه محل بالسوق الا لفيته ولا موقع يعتب
علي
اخ منكم يا بي يا بيه ايش كانت هذه
الاغنيه بدكم عرس طيب بدي اعمل لكم عرس
هلا بدي اعمل لكم عرس يابا يابا يابا ييه
غنوا معي يلا يلا
وحمول الكف شويه
[موسيقى]
خلوني اكمل لكم باخرها والله صرنا باخرها
المهم مرقت الايام ومرات السنين
والام نديمه لابسه اسود باسود
وجنبها بطله كمان لابسه اسود باسود بس في
حدا حاضنها جنبها اثنين صغار بنت وولد
وكانت بطلي بطبطب على الام نتيمه كان عزا
الشده عتيقه
وصار اخر حوار
الام نديمه بتحكي والله رح اشتاق لها بس
ما رح اشتاق للي عملته فيه وما رح اشتاق
انها كانت تخاف من الناس
فبترد بطلي بتواسيها اكيد راح نشتاقلها بس
مين كان يتخيل انه الشده عتيقه اخر عمرها
تتغير
فبترد عليها وهي لساتها زعلانه لام نديمه
وبتقول لها تتذكري لما اجى بطل يتقدم لك
اي كانت رح يغمى عليها من الفرحه انك رح
تتزوجي فبترد بتواسيها بطله وبتقول لها لا
لا لا لا ظلتها اشهر مستغربه انه بطل سندي
وانا سنده وهو ظهري وانا ظهره واحنا مع
بعض بقراراتنا المشتركه واقفين مع بعض
كتير بضحك كانت تطلع علينا هيك فبترد
عليها
الام وبتقول لها بعسل فتره هي كانت مغيبه
هلا ارتاحت
فردت عليها بطله وقالت ياريت لو كانت تشوف
بطل كيف بعامل بنتنا امل هلا او كيف بعامل
كمان شهم اثنين زي بعض بحبوا
بس بتعرفي
كتير مهم تعرف او ما تعرف المهم انا
مبسوطه في حياتي وانا مبسوطه في قراراتي
وخياراتي وبس فردت عليها الام نديمه اخيرا
وحكت انا كتير فخوره فيك يا بطله عملت كل
شي بدك اياه وبنفس الوقت ما ندمتي على
قراراتك
وهيك انا بكون خلصت القصه القصيره وهم
كملوا بحياتهم بس خلينا هيك نتخيل مع بعض
الثلاث شخصيات الاساسيه جدي عتيقه الام
نديمه وبطله جدي عتيقه
بتمثل العادات والتقاليد الباليه هي ابدا
ما بتمثل عادات والتقاليد الحلوه اللي
لازم نضلنا متمسكين فيها
والام نديمه بتمثل المجتمع اشي بايد اشي
بعارض اشي بشوف الغلط وبسكت واشي بحاول
يصلح الغلط بس ما بستمر للتغيير وشيء بندم
على قراراته
بس بطله
هي الانسان والانسانه هي انت او انت اي
حدا فينا بقدر يكون بطل او بطله انا بشوف
حالي بطله قصتي مش بس هيك جايبه معاي
اليوم بطل وبطله معاي امي ميسون بطله
بالنسبه لالي وهي ابدا مش زي ام نديمه
ماما
جوزي كمان اكرم سافر بس ليكون معي اليوم
بتمنى تكونوا بطلات وابطال حياتكم اكتبوها
يعطيكم العافيه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]